what's happy it's like trying to look at
a dog and you say the dog seems happy
I'm not sure I know how that dog seems
or how that dog feels are they healthy
you know absolutely
the life of the monkey from start to
finish is characterized by unmitigated
pain terror suffering psychological
torment and eventually death animal
testing first and foremost is cruel it's
unethical it cannot be justified you
know you hear a lot of pleas from the
activists that in fact there are
computer models and other ways in order
to test vaccines and text drugs but the
reality is you know the animals are
critical at this point in time FDA
requires certain testing to be done
before different vaccines are going to
be allowed into human trials there's
widespread acknowledgment noting that
animal tests are not effective in
predicting human outcomes the animals
apart important for moving drugs from
the bench and to humans we'd like to see
all of those monkey farms shut down
immediately everybody wants to see it go
that way except of course the person who
runs primate product
I'm Thomas J RAL I'm president and chief
operating officer of primary products we
play a pivotal role in providing animals
for use in biomedical research right now
we're probably currently maintaining
about 1,500 maybe 2,000 animals cause a
lot of times clients will ask that
animals are specifically trained and do
various tasks target
there's a lot of time and a lot of
effort involved in training and
sometimes it's more cost-effective for
clients to have us do that training and
buy a conditioned animal as opposed to
moving the animals to their sites and
them doing the training
what we have over here we have our poles
we have our chairs and we have our
monkeys the pole allows us basically to
safely take the monkey out of the cage
it allows us to control the monkey to
train it to walk with us and to operate
with us basically we guide her into the
chair and she kind of walks up it and
then her collar slides into the chair
and then what our job is for the monkey
we offer her a reward again if she wants
it what it allows the researcher to do
is they get to work with an awake
primate that they're not physically
having to restrain and it's kind of a
more of a willing worker cooperative
situation it's just an all-around better
way to work with the primates that are
helping us with research
you
a lot of my work involves working on
pitas undercover investigations where we
send people to work undercover inside
facilities where animals are used and
abused such as primate products
incorporated the core idea is that just
because we can use animals doesn't make
that infliction of pain and suffering
right and at the end of the day 99.99%
of the monkeys are killed their bodies
are dissected and they're trashed after
we shared our information and
documentation with the US Department of
Agriculture primate products
incorporated was cited for more than 25
violations of the federal Animal Welfare
Act
the idea of addressing activists
directly it's really a losing
proposition I like to spend my time
trying to address first off our
employees second off the people in the
industry and also people in the
community and the public I think trying
to convince the activists one way or the
other is really a futile attempt
primary products is not new to activist
activities animal active as a whole more
or less resent the use of animals in
biomedical research and to some extent
animal use at all if in fact the
activists were to get their way I think
that would greatly hamper public health
issues as it stands today and the
advancement of various vaccines and our
drugs that are critical for human life
nine out of ten drugs that are found to
be okay in animals fail in human beings
we can do better by human health by
investing in non animal technologies
that are faster cheaper and more
effective on bringing drugs to market
you
you